a Massachusetts man has been toiling in
his backyard on an epic passion project
for seven years building a 38-foot
wooden sailboat using boards cut down
from his own property with a possible
launch now just months away Brook Silva
bragger decided to check in on him and
he joins us now good morning to you good
morning Dana well in 2015 Steve Dennett
had two college degrees but no real
career after a stint teaching he was
working at a Climbing gym but since
childhood he'd hung on to a nagging
dream of someday building a boat from
scratch and sailing it around the world
well on his 30th birthday he decided to
do it cashing in his life savings and
the life he knew seven years later for
Dennett and those around him so much has
changed you can see what really what
we've been building
wow
I mean it looks like a boat it looks
like a boat yeah and every stage of the
process that's what people say ah it
looks like a boat oh it finally looks
like a boat oh now it looks like a boat
when the process started Steve Dennett
knew nothing about boat building but
making one from scratch he estimated
back then would take him as much as 10
years when we first started and I was
like I'm gonna cut down the trees and
build a boat and everyone's like you're
crazy and it was always what about
significant other what about kids what
about career what about what about what
about what about yeah yeah and then we
would talk to people who are in their
70s their 80s they would go do it you
have the stream go do it what are you
waiting for do you think it's because
they couldn't do it anymore or because
why do you think the difference in the
generations I think they understand what
a lifetime is and what you actually have
the time for and what you're going to
look back on and wish you had or hadn't
done
so in January 2016 Dennis so that guy's
a white oak with no Gray the beard yet
started cutting trees how was that it
was good that was good made Splash you
his friend Alex creeder agreed to help
and make videos how did they go today
when when it was done they'd go sailing
together
filmed as the logs became boards and as
those oak boards were steamed down she
goes until they could be bent into their
new shape you have a matter of minutes
to get them bent into the boat before
they Harden and become non-playable
again and then you just fire in the are
they rivets or rivets yep so there are
square copper rivets and we couldn't
find them big enough anymore we made a
machine to make the rivets
the plan to fund the project was for
Creator to make these videos to drum up
donations through a crowdfunding site so
the first Keel bolt is in and yesterday
we bolted up the stem here but for a
long time the money didn't come for two
years Dennett and krita had to keep
their day jobs and scrounge for supplies
for the lad we needed 12 000 pounds
total where do you find 12 000 pounds of
lead you hunt for a year and a half
so where do you go hunting for lead I
literally would ask every single person
that I had a conversation with do you
know where I can get some lead hold on a
second if you ask a hundred people that
question how many have a positive answer
for you one or two
but sometimes you strike cold or lead I
talked to a woman and her daughter and
they're like actually yeah my husband
has a tire shop so we went and picked up
2 000 pounds of wheel weights figuring
out how to pour our own Keel has been a
trying part of this project the video of
melting that lead and pouring it into a
keel went viral on YouTube and acorn to
Arabella caught on donations in YouTube
ad money let Dennett and creeder quit
their jobs and build full time the
attention also brought more and more
help paid and mostly unpaid people like
Dennett drawn to doing something exotic
and hard for reasons they struggle to
fully explain KP polea was supposed to
start college but took a job here
instead that's it the confusing part is
you had already tried boat building well
I love boat building but then you left
boat building correct because it didn't
pay enough that's right but this pays
much more than that no so that's where
I'm trying to understand that's fair
that's fair it's going to start coming
down a little bit okay nine-year-old
Aaron Wayans volunteers every Friday
I'll try my hardest this was his first
time using a Disc Sander
here 76 year old Joe Damon arrived with
four Decades of experience on the
Bridgeport machine that happened to be
donated just before he came by how do
you find out about this my wife spotted
it because it's in Granby I said our
Granby or Granby Connecticut she says no
Granby Mass
went out and jumped in my truck and came
over how long ago was this
six years something like that you've
been coming here for six years
yeah those gears haven't just
transformed the wood but the people
working it crater is about to be a
married dad he's already helping take
care of his own father he won't be
voyaging with Dennett put our hearts and
souls in this together for a long time
and then to to have them step away is
definitely hard but you know I think he
made the right choice for sure but as
he'd been warned Devotion to the
Arabella did make it hard for Dennett to
find love all of the time building the
boat I don't think any woman was past
like two dates before they were like
yeah I don't see myself on a boat like
I'm stepping out of this one that is
until he met Robin Agricola who had
already been hoping to explore the world
from a camper van I was like yeah you
know I want to like live this nomadic
lifestyle and he's like I see your van
and I raise you uh 38 foot wooden
sailboat if all goes as planned they'll
launch the boat in June it's a small
Cozy home though Dennis will Captain it
at least at first yeah
I'm not a sailor I don't come from that
background we've skipped over this
haven't we we have yeah your sailing
background is non-existent at all yeah
never sailed I maintained the first boat
I sail on I'll be the one I built
oh I sure hope you'll like it I know
you've heard that but come on sure hope
you like it I do too and I think I will
and honestly if I don't I've learned so
much building the boat I have grown so
much I've met such amazing people and
connections and even if I hated sailing
I I would not regret any of this
a couple of weeks ago after our visit
Steve actually stepped back from the
project to spend more time with his mom
who was just diagnosed with an
aggressive form of cancer he's trying to
get enough help so they can still finish
the vote by June and he wants to take
her for a sale well we certainly wish
the Busters
what a story yeah I mean the community
that was built around it that has been
built around it just the idea and
following your passions the people and
yeah and there's so many things I want
to Google why LED for Akil I wanna it
used to be heavy and dense and I really
want to know about this boat when they
put it on the water
I asked him that you have nightmares
about its thinking and he said no way
know-how I am very confident in what
I've made that's great never never
sailed before never built a boat before
I'm gonna build a boat and sail let's do
it money on him thank you so much bro